[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
everybody loved hook except for critics
and everybody loved the Lost Boys except
for critics and the one lost boy that
everybody loved the most including
critics is Rufio I'm not a character
from the original story Peter Pan the
new leader of the Lost Boys has gained
popularity as well the cool Lost Boy
everybody seemed to love this kid
because it seemed like he was the
awesome rebel it was even hinted that
with every boy coming from a different
time period rufio's time period was most
likely the eighties as if he couldn't be
more badass already but fans still
loving the character rufio's actor dante
basco shown here in this dignified file
footage did a crowdfunding campaign to
put together a short based around the
character that shorts name is bang
finally we have a backstory - mr. skunk
head with too much mousse and it seems
to have the blessing of the person who
obviously knows the most about the
character Dante Basco is it we're
checking out well let's take a quick
look and see this is my review of
bangerang well Senor Rufio was said to
be an 80s kid the film starts out in
present-day sounds about right babies
are everywhere now we see our young
leave his name rufus having a sword
fight on a playground as kids do and
some adults
well that bully approaches them no bad
for me go Wow they're like medieval
times waiting staff committed to this
why do I get the feeling you're all
gonna be the D&D player nobody likes to
play with he as long as you don't mail
used condoms to your friends I'm good
buddy the hell are you doing you this is
a kids you late to your audition for
Greece you're not even wearing your
jacket he gets in a fight with the bully
and it's called two principal cameos
office you play football sports I
believe in things oh you're a believer
you're a dreamer what do you dream about
like how the moon landing was faked
Nucky We Need to Talk
I can't well how are you supposed to
live out your dreams if you don't
remember
you know I used to be like Sid oh
nothing in the middle we need to address
that twirl if he forgets what he
believes well he believed he was Billy
Elliot for a second and he should be
reminded mad at the world because of
things I thought I could control but one
thing going for me and one thing that
would keep me up when life is down
catching the avatar alright I know you
were all counting down to that joke
here's the winning timestamp a single
memory that I held tight and close to my
heart
a happy one yeah homework oh that's a
cute who believes in fantasies I've
never heard of this story I don't really
pay attention to things unless there's a
Disney film about it
Rufus goes home to meet with his friends
but sadly they have to be told some bad
news I will be going back to the
Philippines for a time and Rufus will be
going to a foster home forever no not
forever until the family adopts him or
until I can come back really I didn't
think anyone wanted to adopt a 13 year
old boy but 13-year old boy is sitting
right next to you sensitivity training
as long as you don't get a bunch of
tattoos and dye your hair red need I
remind you of your uncle Ronald
she's obviously anxious about leaving
Rufus as represented by a crossfade
though so anxious to start he forgot to
actually fade in as foofa's tries to
escape and to his stories of Peter Pan
we for a kid not interested in football
or sports he sure does have a lot of
football and sports on this walls what
the hell
gopu use your Super Saiyan power to keep
me here or a sword weird choice oh wait
you're Sonic from Black Knight that's
even better I think next day he's
rapping with his friends literally
that's not bad but nothing beats Peter
banning when he's off-camera when Gianni
mentions a certain word imma be a star
fan so the load up
bangerang
Oh 609 million views disagree but the
bully comes back to start trouble what's
he doing trying to fly what you heard me
trying to fly okay
trying to fly I'll tell you what if you
fly for me right now I'll make sure to
leave you and your friends alone forever
on top of it I'll buy all the kids on
this playground shirts with copyrighted
images there are way too many stripes
and solid colors up here but if you fall
I'll make sure your legs aren't the only
things that are
I had a dream that I was attacked by an
80 school portrait thank God there were
no lasers this time okay I know this is
gonna sound crazy what I go to sleep I
start to fly
that does sound crazy all I dream about
is camp it's rubbing oil on my nipples
like normal kids maybe this year
subconscious dealing with the whole
foster care thing in our 40 away what
are you just dream tikka Floyd really
we're done
but Rufus can't shake the feeling that
he might be meant for greater things I
feel like I'm meant to be somebody like
I'm special
sounds stupid when I say it out loud but
it's how I feel I mean I can totally see
myself getting stabbed by a short Jewish
pirate I don't know why I feel like
that's my destiny what if my dreams
don't come true that's your father
talking Steven Wright is a pretty lousy
parent but he decides he wants to change
his look and challenge the bully to a
fly off oh that's too bad I told you you
couldn't fly how about you and your
little friends here go
wait till I tell my friends I made fun
of you wait I don't hang around anyone
why don't you make fun of me but Rufus
Jesus is himself and achieves the power
of flight
[Music]
the kids reactions are all great but
this one kid in particular cracks me up
she's seeing a boy flying she has a look
that says I can make money on this I put
together five different business plans
for this to make me rich
[Music]
I am silently pissing myself every color
known to man right now
[Music]
you are the Oh
this wins the bully's jacket but Chandi
wonders how he pulled it off
where were the wires you know it was
real Jelani I just think it's gonna add
he just floated don't you think he's
flying Jelani okay I want to live or
whatever mind set under plays all this I
know kids have wild imaginations but if
I saw this I want kisses ring finger and
say name fight for a sacrifice Oh Lord
Rufus says goodbye to his mother but
rather than go to a foster home he pulls
a Birdman and leaves out the window
[Music]
[Applause]
my god he's become an american dragon
anytime stand for that he arrives in
Neverland
I hope I'm figuring this isn't what you
see when you land face first in the
House sidewalk and grabs the sore that
Pan himself left behind
I will stop there being more pirate of a
Caribbean sequels
and that was bang rang a very charming
and delightful fantasy it definitely has
its clunky moments but the passion and
simple message of it is too likeable to
overlook the colors are very soothing
it's shot nice and it's given us a
backstory we've always wanted to know
everyone involved is clearly trying to
capture the magical feeling of being a
kid and believing in stories like Peter
Pan but also having it challenged by the
fears of harsh reality this very much
delivers an innocent and positive look
into the benefits of taking a chance on
your dreams and fantasies it's got a lot
of heart and whimsy and deserves to be
checked out
and if you like to you can go to Dante
Bosco's YouTube channel and view it in
its entirety give it a click and guess
what the way I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
ever met
hey critic oh hey don't fire ban me over
this I like the film no I know I know I
just wanted to thank you for giving it a
fair shot you mean you didn't even mind
why I made fun of it well hey it's a
passion project about following your
dreams and it's something as small as
that got in the way then it wasn't that
great of a passion or dream now was it
oh well thanks so much man it's good to
know you're still the awesome guy
everybody says you are now the balm that
I strap under your desk that's gonna
explode when you stand up that I put
there cuz I just don't like you fair
enough I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember what was that last part
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing arc
of the United States
this is the largest national
community-based organization advocating
for and serving people with intellectual
and developmental disabilities they
encompass all ages in all spectrums from
autism to Down's syndrome to other
various developmental disabilities the
arc is driven by opportunity the
opportunity for hope growth change and
everyone to become a valued contributing
member of their community they
strengthen people with disabilities
their parents and family members with
dedicated professionals connecting them
across their national network of
community-based chapters if you look at
their site and their YouTube channel you
can see the collective voice that
provides the opportunity for all of us
to make a difference look and see how
you too can help people with
developmental disabilities and their
families achieve full and satisfying
lives
[Music]
you